all right let's talk about this uh
speaking of cancel culture let's talk
about people should be cancelled from
the daily mail black lives matter
secretly used six million dollars in
donations to buy luxurious 6500 square
foot mansion with seven bedrooms and
parking for 20 cars in southern
california in 2020 where the leaders
have filmed youtube videos
absolutely amazing emails show the firm
wanted to keep the purchase a secret
despite filming a video on the house's
paddy holmes patty in may the news comes
the foundation faces federal scrutiny
for alleged misuse of donation funds and
comes in the heels of criticism of
co-founder patrice cullers culler's 38
came under fire last year for a slew of
high-profile property purchases she
resigned after facing backlash from
critics and supporters and uh i'm
willing to bet that if you go to any
democrat activist or left-wing person
and say hey this is bad right they'll go
well i mean it you know it's but so what
i mean well this is not black lives
matter and it's just you can point out
the money's missing that their address
isn't real that they bought mansions
this lady's got multiple homes and
they'll still just be like but but but
but
yeah you see i i don't i don't i don't
know if there's an equivalent is there
an equivalent like blm on the right not
really no no black lives matter is an
aberration on society and it's very
unique it's like a communist uh
aberration
there's a bold statement intentionally
seated i mean whether or not they the
communists wanted to create it i don't
think so but it's it's very uh it's been
infiltrated
well and the person who's done a lot of
good reporting on this because i just
want to give him a shout out i used to
work with him andrew kerr he's i believe
the washington examiner now and he was
the one who broke this story about last
year black lives matter has this like 60
million dollar war chest essentially and
he found out that there was no one in
charge of it for eight months
like nobody knew where this money was
what they were doing with it who
actually had access to it
and then patrice callers who had
resigned over buying all of these homes
in the backlash that accompanied that
claim that there were two other people
who were supposed to be in charge of
blm's finances and then they found out
that those two people had never even
officially taken over that position
and they still haven't provided any
answers they've tried to delay the
reporting of
their previous fiscal year finances and
just across the board there's all this
corruption that's going on in blm and
like to me this is just the latest
example of how
irresponsible they've been with all this
money who people i think a lot of people
probably donate to blm not to look
racist honestly i don't think they
actually know
like the ins and outs of the
organization
cult
yeah i support the concept that black
lives do matter and white lives do they
do matter and we should focus on uh
class issues but when i say it's an
aberration i'm talking about the
corporate structure that's taking money
and buying houses yeah and the people
like this should all be uh should all be
transparent and it should all be on some
sort of blockchain i mean it's a little
creepy it's a little early for
blockchain look at this house well
that's a nice conyers georgia house
who's buying this stuff who are these
top brass anyway these people that
that's that's an awesome house right
there i would probably just love to buy
something she has you know this patrice
colors excellent taste
in in homes it's just absolutely
impeccable look at this one even this
one's just so nice it's got a little
little list
they made like a little bar it's got two
stories wow that's nice impeccable this
you know if i was going to be running a
an international non-profit that was
taking money with no accountability that
i could then use to my own discretion i
would totally buy these exact same
houses these are nice houses you might
be able to write them off
maybe maybe maybe start a business with
them rent them out and then when you get
exposed you just resign and then go get
to be rich for the rest of your life
yeah or go work for another activist
organization that would be more than
happy to have you because you can't ever
really be canceled if you work for
people like this
and i think it's interesting that black
lives matter has
they started out trying to claim that
they were all about like the police
brutality issue and then they started
bailing out like actual criminals so i
don't know if you guys remember the
story a few months ago i think it was
there was a situation in louisville
where this democratic activist who is
planning on running for like city
council or something his name is quintes
brown he tried to murder
a mayoral candidate oh yeah and was was
locked up for that and apparently he was
upset that this guy who was a democrat
like wasn't left-wing enough for him
blm went and bailed him out of jail and
you had all of these uh these democrats
like praising this guy for how uh how
great he was as an activist like last
year and just thinking about kyle right
now he attempted to murder a politician
yeah yeah and blm bailed him out and
this is at the exact same time that the
freedom convoy protesters had their
funds seized by on give sengo and all of
these other financial platforms is there
any question that he attempted to murder
the guy no no he walked into the office
and they were like how can we help you
when you pull that out why isn't that
guy in jail right now
what is he like okay so he's
bail's another story if he's not a
flight risk maybe then that's another
conversation completely that this
corporation is bailing out people
it's kind of interesting yeah
black lives matter bailed him out yes
black what happened in illinois the
state gave 300 grand to black lives
matter kamala harris has written
tweeted out a fundraiser for black lives
to well not for black women minneapolis
to bail out the rioters who were
you know i'll be careful here the riots
were very much associated with black
lives matter but i don't want to accuse
the organization of being the same thing
but very much so the left is overt in
doing all this stuff
you know how i feel when we're talking
about twitter as well i was like does it
matter do we care because at this point
it's like why are we acting like we have
anything to do with those people for all
for all you know the way i see it is get
away from the cities
take care of yourself because these
lunatics are going to go smash windows
and destroy businesses there's no
reasoning with them there's no
conversation we are seeing some of them
get charged and sent to jail that this
is you know relatively racist thing
where people are actually getting
charged and convicted but it's like two
or three here or there out of the
hundreds or thousands that were going
through each of these cities and
destroying them so at a certain point
it's like
i just don't consider them to be like
citizens of the world of the country
that i live in
you know there there's two distinct
countries and there's no point
interacting the economy of antifa and
blm does not in any way interact with
the economy here of me
so i just ignore it it's just what's the
point right now oh black lives matter
ripped off all a bunch of dumb people
they're happy they got ripped off they
don't care we're complaining about an
organization we didn't donate to i'm
just like you know what man let people
be ripped off yeah
there was there was a point where i
wanted to to go up to people and beg
listen they're ripping you off they're
taking your money and they're buying
houses but they don't care they like it
so then what do you do
yeah
well you keep doing what you're doing
and don't get derailed by it that's for
sure you make better software technology
i'm not gonna stop making better social
media tech because there's dumb racists
out there uh i will acknowledge them i'm
not gonna completely ignore them but i'm
not gonna let them deviate me from my
path
and you should do the same continue on
your path strong don't i think the issue
is
there was a point where there was an
argument between left and right that we
were one country and we were going
through a
we're having a bitter
period in our relationship
then at some point
the
you know the other half of the
relationship start throwing bricks and
fire bombs and mortars and at that point
you should be like like when when if
you're fighting with your significant
other when they start hitting you is
when you need to leave yeah
yeah so at this point it's like
you want to burn down cities the people
who want to stay there and are fine with
it
i've already given my two cents like you
need to get away from that if you don't
want to okay you're like there's a woman
being battered by your husband and you
you say get away from him and and then
she won't at a certain point you're like
i've tried what i can try if she won't
leave what am i supposed to do yeah and
this is one of the things that drives me
absolutely crazy about a lot of fellow
conservatives is that they still like
desperately want the approval of the
left whether it's like corporate media i
mean for example i'll go back to the
trump administration one of my biggest
complaints with them was that they were
constantly feeding scoops and you know
leaking to the new york times and in the
washington post and it's like why are
you constantly rewarding the people who
hate you
no matter what you do these people are
never going to think that you're a good
person they're never going to accept you
they're never going to think the way
that you do about issues or policy
they're always going to think that
you're evil and yet constantly so many
people on the right fall into this trap
of thinking if i could just do this one
thing i could change their mind this is
part of the reason it was so frustrating
to me to watch trump try to get on the
side of the media yeah he would make fun
of them and he's like oh lion mainstream
media or whatever but you know it at the
end of the day he was like well i really
actually do care what the new york times
says about me he kept doing sit down
interviews with them why was the trump
administration inviting people from cnn
to go have
background briefings with administration
officials and letting them have
exclusive quotes in in interviews and
stories it's crazy to me it was trump's
nostalgia yeah why didn't trump get on
gab or mines
why didn't he do a daily youtube video
blog i mean he had everything in front
of him but he was from he's from the 50s
1950s or whenever he was born or he
didn't have anybody in his
administration who could tell him like
hey you need to directly connect with
people better
i think it was kind of both right i
think part of it was that he
longed for the days when he was adored
by the media and was this you know
superstar that could do no wrong and and
people really glorified him and then it
was also the staffing issues where he
did have a lot of staff members who were
either actively undermining his
administration or just really stupid and
not very good at their jobs well
ignorant that's a good way because they
just didn't know the about the
technology they didn't know how to do it
is it not necessarily stupid they might
have also been stupid i don't know
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there